こんにちははじめしゃちょーです第1回の
おうちで100人かくれんぼ
他の人を連れてきた皆さんもう壊れ始め
社長の3億円のおうちこの家何がすごい
かって言うとでかいんですよただひたすら
にでかいもう一人で痛くないです広すぎて
本当にこのスペースどうしようかって思っ
た時に
あれこれよく考えたら100人ちょっと
入れるんじゃねえと思いまして今回なんと
エキストラ100人の方を準備して今もう
お家に入っていただいておりますすごく
ない自分の家にを人が100人隠れてるの
よありえないというわけでルールです
鬼は僕ですはじめしゃちょーが100人を
見つけます見つけるので先にエキストラ
100人の方にお家に入っていただいて
隠れ場所を探してもらいました
[拍手]
皆さん今日はお集まりいただきありがとう
ございますじゃルール説明しますね
ルールは制限時間長いと多分皆さん辛いと
思うので30分で
40分でお願いしますちょっと長いと思う
んですけども何度か隠れていただけると
助かります皆さんも
隠れ場所を決めましたか
[音楽]
俺は外で待ってるので皆さん隠れて
ください
[音楽]
ライブ会場だこれ
[笑い]
よし行くぞ
ということで
100人かくれんぼうスタート
これ何回に何人いるか一応情報として
聞けるのでちょっと聞いときましょう何人
いますこれ1階に24人一回24人2階に
193階に20人なるほど4階に37人4
回じゃあまずは1回ちょっと探してみよう
かよっぽど見つからなかったら上行き
ましょうマジで本気で探しに行こう
エレベーターに多分ね1人いるんだよあの
隠れ方してるって事はやっぱりそんなない
んだよ実は隠れれそうな場所が絶対1人出
てくるから今ここ
いないね
[音楽]
こういう中とか
さすがに
びっくりしたいやいやいや独特だよ見つけ
ました
どんなに今日本当に
[音楽]
いやいやいやもう
可愛いな
どんどん行くよまずねそこに1人です
見つけました
あここにも1人いる見つけましたお家に
女性隠れてるってなんかいいねあこれ絶対
この中にはい見つけました
これ100人見つけられなかったら家に
知らない人残ってる可能性あるから
ここもいる見つけました
あと13人
じゃ見つけましたよちょっと待って子供
ちっちゃくてわかんないわあんな
ちっちゃい子いるんだったらちょっと話
変わってくるとマジで
大丈夫だよな今5分半そこそ
こ見つけました確定わかってる
俺さっきここ開いてたの見たんだ
[音楽]
嘘だ
あれ
いない
いないわやばい
急げ1回まだいる
11人
1回で
[音楽]
も普通におじいちゃん歩いとるだけじゃ
ないか3人見つけましたよ
会合みたいになってる
そしてここも1人見つけました見つけまし
た
さすがにまだ外にえーすご
いやもうホラー映像見つけました
ここも見つけはお二人え3人いるんだここ
[笑い]
見つけました限界の隠れ方してるけどあと
3人1回出た3人いるらしいです
たまにこう難易度出てくるの
見つけました
あと2人
いや俺の予想だと多分前庭はもういない気
がするちょっと待って本当にまずいぞ何人
か簡単だったけど突然今やばい難易度の
感じがあった
11分
[音楽]
ちょっと待ってくれます
いや可能性があるとしたらでも
ここもでもダメだもんね
え
っやっ
た
見つけられないとこでしたよ
え待って結構ビビるわやっぱ人が多いから
簡単な人もいるんですけどたまに行かれた
難易度の人が出てくるぞあと一人でしょ
[音楽]
1回で13分経ってます
いや俺の心当たりはもうないぞここ
ちょっと1回諦めます時間もないから一人
見つけられなかった時間に余裕があったら
また来よう2回行きます
2回行くぞー
2階が2階が19人ねよし行くぞまずは
この
和室から失礼しますよまずは一人目見つけ
ました
多分2人ぐらいいるんじゃないのかな
思う中に入ってるの
もう1人見つけました
でまた結構いるな見つけました結構いるぞ
ここ見つけましたこれ中にいるんだよ
[音楽]
やばいやばい
よく入ってましたね
6人見つけました大丈夫次行きましょう
あと13人か
いましたいました
あーいました色同化しとるしやめときまし
た
どこだ
馴染んどる見つけました
隠れる場所が当たらなかった
ね
いやいやいやいやずっとシャワー浴びてた
の見つけました
よかったです
やばいやばいやばい
見つけました
はいはいはいはいそうですよね
ここでも見つけましたちょっと待って
意外とゾーン隠れてるな
うわいるわいるわ
見つけましたよありがとうございます
見つかっちゃいましたあと3人待ってこれ
以上俺結構引き出し全部出したぞ
[音楽]
もう20分20分
いやマイGのパターンあるかプロ確認ある
んで割と経験値あるんですよかくれんぼの
ただこういうトイレとかに3人でしょ
いやめっちゃおったよ見つけましたよ
なるほどねトイレにもいるのね
こっちはいないかなうわ
いた
びっくりした見つけました
2回もう1人いるもんね
結構
視力を潰したよでもなるべく時間内に
たくさん見つけたいからちょっとここも
1人残しておきましょう
20人いますいや3回結構狭いからすごい
びっくりした
びっくりしたガチの不審者かと思った
見つけましたちょっと待ってくれよ
トイレにまず一人います見つけました
ストレッチされてますね
あと18人
編集部屋行きましょうかおっと
暗くなってるな
めっちゃ女の人おる見つけました
見つけましたかくれんぼの概念が何か
わかんなくなった
ここにもう一人どういうことこれ
どういうこと
見つけました
机の下だな見つけました
悔しいか俺の経験上これ
びっくりした
びっくりした見つけました
かくれんぼというか人が多すぎて怖いこれ
見てください板外してあるんですよこれ板
外してやるということは
[音楽]
こんにちは
ここはもういないでしょうきっと
いや落ち着けそんな簡単に
見落とすところでした
びっくりした
フェイクだったらねあの最初の2人はここ
はもういない大丈夫大丈夫
ここはもういない
ここもいるでしょ
髪の毛洗っとる掃除しとる
ありがとう
隠れられないんだな
新してきます
でここも足が見えてて見つけました
あと何人だ
びっくりした
衝撃衝撃あと
3人
[音楽]
恐怖よ見つけました
怖い怖い怖いあと2人
おーいた
びっくりした見つけました
各階に1人ずつやばい人が隠れてるん
だろうなここじゃないかないや絶対これ
だあ
びっくりしたー
びっくりしたちょっと待ってお
じいちゃん出てきた寝ちゃった
これで3階はコンプリートかな4回行き
ます時間がない皆さんありがとうござい
ます4階に来ました4回37人です
ちょっと
広いですわ
あれパッドで見当たらんぞ
[音楽]
あれ
いやまずね不自然にこうなってるのは多分
いるんですね
見つけました
6つちょっと待って高
難易度だな相当まだいるって事だここも
多分
あれ
[音楽]
やっば見つけましたちょっと待って4回
難易度高いかどんどんいきますね
弟の寝室多分小顔さすがに一人は寝ている
寝ていないが角度がおかしいぞよいしょ
えどういうことずっとベッドに
潰されてたの見つけましたありがとう
ございます
ここで30分経過しましたあと10分で
ここにも1人いるんですよねもう一人
見つけました見つかりましたで多分なんだ
けどここにも一人いますね
心配になっちゃう大丈夫ですか見つけまし
た
どんどんいっちゃいますね時間が結構もう
いないよな
この中とか見ないよ
大丈夫だと思いたいここだ
はいはいこんにちは見つけましたよもう
一人見つけましたよ
ここ見つけて二人
どこだ
あーいたマジで見つけました
お疲れ様です
ねここもまずあ違う今人がいたみたいな
大丈夫ですか
これ多分俺だと入れないな見つけました
あと27人ちょっと待ってマジでやばい
よし
どういうこと人の痕跡があるんだけどまず
いつも通り机の下にはいますね見つけまし
た
多分ここにも1人あれこれ中に入ってるの
どういうシステム
簡単そうに見えてちょっと数が多いから
しっかりカーテンにいますね
靴だった
びっくりした何人いる2人2人
多分グリーンバックの中にもいますね
見つけました
えあと21人ちょっと待ってマジやばい
ごめんちょっと頑張りますね
急ぎます大地君の部屋
天聖これやばいわあと5分
ここ
ないって
見つけました
怖い
びっくりしちゃういやまだここで安心する
ね
そんなマニアックなことないよね
だめだプロのせいで
めっちゃ注意深くなってるお風呂場
浴槽に2人見つけましたでカーテンにも
一人いますね
4人捕まえたからあと16
どういうこと
びっくりした見つけました
フェイントでもう一人いますね
これもフェイントで多分
いますね
行きますよ待って黒い部屋やばいよ
なるほどこれは
びっくりした一人見つけましたこれも多分
これどういうシステムなんだこれ
えお菓子めっちゃ入ってる
すごい長い時間よく言いましたね
2人見つけました1分半
この部屋
密度濃いからここも1人いますね見つけ
ました
ここも多分1人いる
見つけました
もう一人いる
見つけた大丈夫
熱かったでしょう
あと1分ですあと1分あと1分ね6時だと
1分
いや絶対ないです
[音楽]
1人見つけましたどこどこ
まずい
無理無理無理
この部屋かいるのか
あと5人でしょう
[音楽]
[拍手]
ということで40分やった結果100人中
93人見つけられましたが7人無理でした
でも時間との戦いだったね結構4回やっぱ
5人残ってたんで雑になっちゃった時間が
なかったでも12回に1人ずついるん
でしょ
テントつかないもんねプロかくれんぼ球
いるさては
ちょっとえげつなかったなちょっと
答え合わせも含めて4階から探していき
ましょうか5人いるはずよねこの部屋まだ
隠れている人いますか
あそこもう一人いたのねお疲れ様です
すごい
こっちともう一人いたんだこっちに
ちょっとこれを焦ってたねまだいます
いないかなじゃあこの
編集部屋
見事逃げ切った人いますか
[音楽]
こんな部屋はいないのね
続いてこの大地君の部屋
逃げ切った人いますか
ここもいないんだお風呂場逃げ切った人い
ますか洗濯
室いますか
いやいないよねトイレいますかいないです
ね黒い部屋まだ隠れてる人
マジですか
お
めでとうございます他にいますかこの部屋
どこだひょっとして
箱の中
これさ丁寧におもちゃもさ戻されてると
やっぱわかんないわお疲れ様です
いやすごい大丈夫ですか見事逃げ切りまし
たおめでとうございます
いやもう酸素薄くてあ自分の足の匂い
ずっと嗅いでこれうまいわものをもう一回
置き直してたのがマジでわかんなかった
この辺はまだいますかもういないか
見事逃げ切りましたありがとうございます
この中ってことですか
最後1人いますかに来た人
[音楽]
やばいですって
それはわかんないですよこれは多分時間
なくても
難しかっただいぶ限界のこれ
逃げ切りましたおめでとうございます
ありがとうございますこれで4階の人は
見つかったんですけどもあと1回と2階に
1人ずついるっていうちょっと見に行き
ましょうかじゃあ2階の答え合わせです
結構
厳しくね割とさ広い場所だからそんな
見つけられないことあるかな
さあまだ隠れてる人いますか
ここじゃない風強い
逃げ切った人いますか
腰やられちゃったよずっとここにいたのね
なるほどね
ここにいましたこの1回ちょっとやってみ
てもらってもいいですか
最初
そこのあそうなんだよ
逃げ切りました2段重ねたときついね結構
1階にも1人逃げ切った人がいるみたい
です
探しに行きましょう
逃げ切った人いますか
隠れきった方こっちの部屋かないやこっち
の部屋はないでしょまだ
隠れてる人いますか
うんさすがにこの部屋じゃない多分少ない
ですよねまだ隠れてる人いますか
どこに行ったんですか
全然
わかんなかった
逃げ切りました